it's time for roses and rose Bay Oh the
higher the hair the closer to Joe Joe
you guys Monday night's episode of The
Bachelorette
was everything we had to shocking exits
Luke and chase let's start off with Luke
so we're in an airport hangar everyone's
here is huge I think their hair is all
getting really long to take it to have
here cuts while they're on the show I
don't know I'll try to find out Luke
tells Jojo he loves her it doesn't
matter she still sends him home babies
but the exit you guys Luke's face Luke's
face Luke's face it was like someone had
kidnapped his firstborn child it was
like someone had murdered his dog in
front of his eyes it was like someone
told him that in actuality his parents
were not his parents it was like someone
told him that this is not the year 2016
is actually 1935 and he's been dead for
a hundred years Luke was shocked he did
not see this coming
it was so clear I was just like crying
and clawing at the screen I wanted to
help him look for Bachelor not for long
though my feelings are gonna change on
this so here's the thing we were really
upset about Luke for about 10 minutes
but then Thailand
cheers to Thailand two bright colors and
two moving on from trauma we're in
Thailand it's time for fantasy sleuths I
always wonder do they happen one night
after the other I don't know I'll try to
find that out too so first up we have to
reassure Jojo that his feelings are
thrille Robby gives her a note from his
dad okay
then he called her Joelle which i'd
honestly forgotten was her name and then
they slept together Cheers
oh I gotta give Jojo a little credit on
her morning-after look girl was working
a messy bun and some cute shorts and she
looked great on that walk home that
pondering thoughtful walk home anyway
Ravi's coming on strong next up Arden
and then they sleep together Cheers
you'll notice a pattern here but that
pattern is about to be broken
enter chase guys guys guys
I thought Luke's exit was crazy and then
we had chase
literally stress eating peanut M&Ms like
it was nobody's business
yeah so they're at the fantasy suite we
know it's hard for Chase to say I love
you he is a child of divorce
of a broken home and on the doorstep of
the fantasy suite chase says to her I
love you 100% in love with you and Jojo
says I need a minute
can you hold on one minute and literally
leaves she walked away Jesus is back
there drinking what else is he gonna do
what I do so Jojo returns and tells
chase that she does not feel the same
way right after he told her he loved her
which he has never done first in a
relationship ever and JC just takes a
drink I get the point I just threw
myself out there jumped over a hurdle
I've never jumped over before and now
I'm skewered he storms off and she
chases him and he cracks the beer to get
in the van and he says he regrets saying
and he says he feels like he's gotten
kicked in the nuts and chase oh you're
so good-looking
chase for bachelor yeah I told you I
changed our mind did you guys change
your mind it was like first I was
onboard with Luke then I was in birth
chase but also I'm thinking chase was a
little aggressive they're dropping some
f-bombs I don't know but wait the rose
ceremony so Judah shows up and Ravi and
Jordan are both in blue shirts and
khakis and then chase walks in also
wearing a blue shirt and khakis Ravi and
Jordan are literally sweating with
nerves here's what this was guys they
make good just in case chase might be
the next Bachelor he had to come back
and apologize to Jojo in a gentlemanly
way and he did it and literally chase
has never looked better in this episode
and he was so handsome and okay I've got
it
Zack chase
no wonder following a hook become so
hard chase still goes home Cheers
to chase what episode I'm gonna drink
this down like he'd drink down that beer
in that van oh so you guys what do you
think Luke for bachelor or chase for
bachelor I'm very torn
Luke is a sexy war veteran Chase is a
sexy what is he to again either way
they're both great they both came off
great in this episode and what an effort
was I absolutely loved it we are down to
the final two next week is the finale
Jordan our Robbie Robbie our Jordan
Jordan or Jordan those are our options
let me know who you think should be the
next Bachelor and who Jojo should pick
over on Twitter and be sure to subscribe
to ETS YouTube channel for all sorts of
hilarious videos that some which include
alcohol thank you and good night